Today, more than ever, we communicate on a global scale.
We interact with people from all walks of life.
And we operate in very different linguistic, social and cultural universes.
In this context, successful communication stands out...
...as a key component of companies facing new challenges...
...in a constant search to improve their agility, responsiveness and competitiveness.
Effective communication nurtures cohesion,...
...develops a sense of belonging and enhances performance,...
...both for the individual and for the company.
Telelangue, in its mission of communication facilitator...
...supports you in your strategy to communicate better...
...at every level. Our strength is our experience.
Forty years of expertise, 600 communication facilitators...
...and thousands and thousands of hours of training.
Our know-how is centered on three areas of expertise:...
...Linguistical skills, social skills and intercultural skills.
Telelangue is the facilitating partner you need to open up the field of possibilities...
...and to expand the scope and impact of your communication...
...in a world of perpetual interaction.